is there other studies
of this nature that you foresee enabling
that same kind of positive impact
whether it's mdma
for other things like treating addiction
or maybe it's psilocybin
for uh for other conditions is there
something else that's promising
yeah i i think that um
what we've discovered i don't think is
unique to mdma
so it's mdma assisted psychotherapy
mdma is ideal for ptsd you know
maybe it won't work as well for ocd or
other things you know it was very
strategic why we chose mdma and why we
chose ptsd
but i i don't think that the results
that we've got are so
unique to mdma assisted therapy i think
that psilocybin assisted therapy is
going to be great for
people with life-threatening illnesses
cancer
you know we're anxious about dying it's
looks like it's really good in the
treatment of addiction
again these are in combination with
sort of the psilocybin tobacco was
cognitive behavioral therapy
with psilocybin i think that
it's going to be a little bit more
difficult psilocybin for depression
i don't know if it'll be quite as good
you know there are some biological
aspects sometimes to depression
but i think there'll be really good
results for psilocybin for depression i
think it'll be approved it's considered
a breakthrough therapy by the fda
ibogaine is phenomenal for opiate
addiction helping people go through the
withdrawal and then
giving them this chance to deal with the
material that they've
that drives them for addiction there was
ben sessa dr ben sessa in england did
mdma for alcohol use disorder
and that was really great the results he
got and it's it's the case that
he ended up basically treating people
for trauma it's the trauma that people
run
the emotional challenges that people run
from into
quieting that pain through drug
addiction or alcoholism
so trauma is behind a lot of addiction i
i think that we are going to see
um a revolution in psychiatry
and that there will be a lot of
conditions that have
left a lot of people still suffering
that psychedelic assisted therapy
different psychedelics different
approaches but i think that we will see
a lot of hope for psychiatry and
psychotherapy and that psychedelics
would be a big part of
um changing the practice of of
psychiatry and psychotherapy
yeah this is really to me fascinating so
i i actually um
when i was younger for the longest time
wanted to be a psychiatrist
so i was excited by psychotherapy but
then i
uh perhaps incorrectly maybe you can
correct me but
became more and more cynical because it
felt like it was more about prescribing
drugs than psychotherapy
i'm not going to correct you that's i
mean right now it's like there is a
crisis in psychiatry that there are so
many psychiatrists that are so fed up
because
they have been pharmaceuticalized yes
they meet people for 15 minutes they
adjust their medications
this is the way they make the most money
yeah but they've lost the art of talking
to people yes
it's it's true and that's why we see
that so many young psychiatric residents
are so thrilled by psychedelics that
they really want to get back to
treating people as individuals not just
a bunch of chemicals
yeah that's truly fascinating because
the reason it was appealing to me it was
a way to
to study the human mind and to
see ways through talking that you can
make people feel better make people
better
you know make people suffer less and
that that was really exciting at the
time i ended up then going to ai because
then
i can understand the mind from that
angle but um
it's exciting that that that could be
also
a revolutionize the field of
psychotherapy take it from its
uh back to its origins to where um a
psychiatrist
would be a scholar of the mind yeah well
you know freud talked about
dreams as the royal road to the
unconscious and there was a lot of
you you really spent a lot of time with
people now
um right before he died um in in his
last book
freud wrote something and again this
will be a rough paraphrase but he said
that in the future
we may learn about the energies of the
brain and there'll be ways with
chemicals to influence that that will
help the therapeutic process yeah so you
could say he was uh
he was ahead of his time yeah
you